And we said there are a couple of other
aspects to a privacy policy other than
collection, use, and sharing, which
is how hard do they work to address
the security of that information?
Many of it's services actually
use extra TPS or use encryption.
I mentioned that they do
stronger authentication,
they do two factor authentication now,
password, and
then they send you, on your phone,
they send you a code that you use.
And they use other safeguards,
we talked about a lot of their technical
safeguards who are protecting
information or securing information.
So they do all these things so the
private information that they have about
you doesn't get into the hands
of malicious actors.
They do have something
about changing the privacy,
all these things we were talking about.
If they want to change any aspect of
these, they will not change them and
change in a waywhere that reduces
your rights without your consent.
So the idea is the privacy policy says,
well,
if we ever want to go to a more
lax privacy policy, okay,
which is what reducing your rights is,
we would ask you, okay?
And only if you consent to that,
we will change the policy.
And so it's a way that you can view
it as more lax than what they had
before, okay?
So repeating the policy says
what we collect, how we use it,
how we share it, how we secure it, and
if anything changes about the policy
what would it take to do that.
Okay, so that's sort of a quick,
brief overview of what a privacy
policy should look like.
We use this example, Google,
but you can go study somebody
else's privacy policy and
see what aspects of the things
that we discussed here are covered in
that policy and what is not covered.